du coup il a il en a convenu que c'était
quand même pas mal qu'on se retrouverait
fort et vous bernard montiel jamais moi
j'y crois pas beaucoup de choses ne
seraient pas ça se travaille
je vous dis alors moi je le dis tout est
disponible vous je vous le dis comme je
le pense
ça veut dire et cela me fait beaucoup
beaucoup de peine vous ne rêvez plus
vous ne vivrez plus je vous jure que
c'est vrai c'est pas ça n'est mis votre
zisis sur silence depuis bieber séville
est en mode avion symphonie est en mode
avion depuis des années ses toiles est
en train de vivre des moments d'une
dispute
je vous le dis les gens ont saisi est en
confinement n'a pu 10 978 m c'est vrai
mais je le dis dans mes collègues ça
c'est la vérité
ces voix là oui j'ai trop peur de
souffrir oui c'est vrai j'ai pas à
chaque fois j'étais très très très forte
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce que vous
avez des expériences difficiles mais à
chaque fois parce que vous savez la mort
quand on se donne comme ça complètement
c'est c'est terrible mais quand ça finit
mal
chacun c'est effrayant très grande
douleur
j'ai du mal à m'en remettre c'est vrai
j'ai beaucoup de mal à m'en remettre je
sais j'ai l'air toujours rigolo enfin
rigolo normes et bonne humeur
moi je montre que cet himalaya dernier
derrière ce sourire oui on y loge social
zad nom est ce qu'il ya une grande
similitude entre blessures il ya de
vraies grandes villes sur une très
grande solitude
enfin bon j'aime bien la musique qui va
avec oui vous êtes seul bernard oui je
suis seul et je le regrette et vu mon
caractère ça va pas s'arranger vraiment
oui pensez que vous terminerez seul oui
alors je me demande toujours qui va
pousser le chariot d'être mamie à
l'ehpad ans déjà prévu que pour vous
vous même parce que vous êtes gentils
avec moi aurait poussé les deux autres
achoppaient on est on est dans un moment
d'émotion c'est vrai mais c'est quoi
votre c'était ça date un savon t'as
quand votre plus belle histoire d'amour
la dernière ou la plus belle la plus
belle il ya longtemps il ya très
longtemps parce qu'on m'a de paille et
ce que j'y crois plus en fait c'est ça
le problème pourquoi un couteau samedi à
damas oui c'était quand cette histoire
d'amour
bernard la dernière sérieusement il ya
il ya maintenant dix ans et alors et
alors depuis c'est le désert m'a fait le
désert
je vois du pays quand il a marqué
l'histoire par les airs voyez quelques
oasis dans le désert
oui bernard mais c'était il ya dix ans
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est vous qui
avez décidé de rompre ou c'est la
personne qui est parti non c'est moi qui
ai foutu le bordel pourront parce que
j'avais trop peur de l'investissement
affectif
ça devenait trop sérieux j'ai eu peur et
j'ai foutu le bordel quoi vous avez peur
comme ça
l'amour cyril j'ai tellement peur de
souffrir
non vraiment vous savez la lumière au
bout de dix ans au bout de dix ans vous
êtes passé commun de toi cas personne
pourtant je suis âgée oui je m'en remet
jamais c'est quand votre plus longue
histoire berne à la plus longue histoire
oh là là mon dieu c'est dur ce que vous
me demandez je crois que c'était la plus
longue histoire a duré six ans voilà six
ans étaient six ans magnifique mais vous
savez quand vous vous investissez
affectivement beaucoup après moi j'ai
peur et je casse tout et mon mauvais
caractère mais vraiment je fais tout
pour que la personne sendai j'ai
beaucoup de souffle même barré alors on
appelle j'ai dit tout ce que j'ai dit
oui là j'en rigole et ça fait du bien
lionel de merde